well congratulations on the success of
what happens in small town with Lindsay
al gets number well another good feeling
hey I was incredible feeling especially
with it being her first number one yeah
you know that my mom was more excited
for her than I am for us so on that in
she's just man she's incredible to work
with and if you know Lindsay at O like
her name synonymous with hard work
everybody in the business shows no she's
a grinder in yes she's a great singer a
great entertainer but she's an
incredible guitar player absolutely you
just don't see the you know many folks
playing like it anymore I am singing so
it was it was an honor to share the song
whether it were real proud of what it
did
she's a proud Canadian she's kicking a
lot of butt in the music world when well
when did you know that she had something
special that you're like we don't work
together we we met in passing through
the years but my mother-in-law on my
wife and I got back together this last
time we were old for like on and off for
five years then we went five years
without seeing her feeding each other
and then you know this last time we min
ago several years but when we got back
together her mom wanted to go to the
Opera so I took her mom and her and her
little brother and we looked to the
operating Lindsay was playing that night
and my brother-in-law fell slapping love
was head over heels but I enjoyed I
really enjoyed the show and was just
blown away without houses she was and
how well she performed
you know when Scott Borchetta the
president of our record label brought
her name up to do that it was like yeah
it's it we have yeah she's one of so
many talented women in country music I
want to get your take on the news
recently you know when CMT saying you
know we're gonna do parody when they
fifty fifty men and women in our music
videos after the whole you know debacle
of some country stations saying oh we
can't play women I play men back-to-back
kind of thing what's your taking all
that Lena
not politicians I kind of hang out them
most of that stuff but I will say that
you know it's it's been a tough time for
females in our job for a long time and
and I'm friends with with several
artists better females are just
incredibly hard workers and and you know
extremely talented people and you know I
want all the good in the world for them
I never have anything but the best
wishes for real artists in their music I
hope it all works out yeah fire
brimstone also another great success man
going number one on Billboard country
charts I you know when you put something
together is that part of the intent we
got to get this thing to number one
what's going on in your head when you
finally get to have your creative when
you're in your creative space no rewards
never a bad day you know but as far as
it being a goal I don't know what I'm
making an album my goal is to tell the
story the best way possible and you know
to really write every song best way I
know how
I'll write them and rewrite them and
rewrite them and you know I spend a lot
of time writing records and then record
them or record making processes
extremely long but you know in terms
also get to micromanage the songs and
yeah and what's being said and all of my
records all my albums tell a story their
chapters of my life and this one's no
different and you know I still believe
in albums even though the rules have
changed and the way people consume music
is different I still like to write a
story it's still like for there to be a
theme and it's just always been
something that I loved about music when
people did that and I've enjoyed doing
it myself
yeah well always outbreak
yeah one of the big parts of this
chapter if your life and maybe the
biggest one is your fatherhood man that
hung the moon is a song that's touched
so many people I mean how do you feel
about the reaction that you get from
them like they on the comments under you
know your YouTube video or people just
talking about how much it means to them
grown man's and their crying over this
all what does it mean to you I'm a grown
man that cried like a baby my wife
actually brought my son to the studio
yeah when I was cutting vocals on that
song and I had to wait til it left it
was just I'm not a crier whatsoever man
but when it comes to my kids it's like
you know that's the one trigger I have
but you know to be completely honest
with you as a writer a lot of times as
you write songs that you feel like her a
real general and relatable and you know
it's never does it always ends up being
the songs that are the closest to your
heart that you know are so specific and
tell a story in such detail that people
really gravitate towards and make their
own and relate to so you know that one
was pleasantly still still pleasantly
surprised that that many people related
to it and and you know made that story
theirs and that's a it's a proud feeling
when you write something that that
invokes an emotion or that somebody can
you know you hear stories about even
what the song does in people's lives
that's one of the best parts about being
a songwriters
now on tour one of the things that I
think your fans really like about you is
that you like to have fun you like to
pull some pranks Lindsay's been the
brunt of it like a lot of give anything
plans you can let us know about no no
we're still getting to know these boys
you gotta go where it hurts you know and
get to the heart of what hurts I wasn't
alone though in that day that that whole
end of tour huh that was insanity
between
her heard Regan Michaels and in mind we
played so many jokes on each other we
went out we stole I forget how many it
was but we went to his work box and got
every meet-and-greet pass he had left
like a hundred more some in handy amount
to random people and I didn't know it
but Carly was surprised that they his
wife was coming surprising and she had
to wait like an hour in the car like
he's supposed to be a surprise she was
gonna come out of the car surprised she
just had to sit western art with a yeah
man it gets uh get savage up there hey
I'm Graham O'Neal for more on your
favorite country stars click subscribe
or watch the videos over there